Henry Cavill's fans aren't the only ones who
are thirsty.
The new face of Geralt of Rivia recently sat
down with Graham Norton back in his native
England to talk about his role on Netflix's
The Witcher.
The scene everyone was desperate for after
the first Witcher trailer arrived - the monster-hunting
Geralt sitting in that famous wooden bathtub,
naked as the day he was born - was the big
clip featured during Cavill's interview with
Norton, and that naturally invited questions
about how he prepared for The Witcher's most
famous scene.
Fans are at least casually familiar in this
age of Thors and Supermen that the diet required
to maintain a perfectly sculpted brickhouse
physique is punishing and mostly comprised
of eating one's weight in boneless, skinless
chicken breasts.
Chatting with Norton about how he got ready
to portray Geralt, Cavill revealed a new twist
in the horror-show that putting perfect bodies
on film necessitates: purposefully dehydrating
himself over several days.
Cavill explained that the worst part about
playing Geralt was the sharp decline in fluid
intake he had to endure to get ready for all
the shirtless scenes.
He told Norton,
"On the first day, you'll have, like a liter
and a half [of water], the second day a half-liter,
and then the third day, no water, and you'll
shoot on the fourth."
He went on to say that by the time he's done
shooting on that fourth day, he's, quote,
"the most miserable person on Earth."
"Bleh!
Dry mouth!"
But why, though?
Isn't putting Cavill through an incredibly
bland and utilitarian diet for months on end
for the sake of vanity enough?
"It makes your skin really thin, so it sits
on the muscles."
This method of purposeful dehydration is a
common one for bodybuilders preparing for
competition or photoshoots, boxers and MMA
fighters trying to drop pounds before weigh-ins,
and actors alike.
Sure, Cavill is still massive in size and
could probably crush a watermelon between
his bicep and forearm, but the high-definition
cut of his musculature requires tricking the
body temporarily.
Warning: We don't recommend trying any of
this without medical supervision!
Dehydrating is the final step in the process
towards a temporary period of maximum muscle
definition, and bodybuilders refer to it as
"peak day."
The first stage, about two weeks before the
target date, requires temporarily increasing
your sodium consumption, which tricks the
body's usual water retention ratio.
At first, it will retain water, but eventually
re-adapt and normalize.
When sodium intake is severely cut a week
later, water will rapidly exit the body along
with it, meaning there's almost no added water
weight or possible bloating because of it.
Along with this process, consumption of carbs
are cut to almost nothing.
This temporarily supercharges burning the
minuscule amount of excess fat left in the
body.
It's a precarious balancing act to increasingly
deprive yourself of water, and yet give your
muscles enough hydration to handle those workouts
that still have to get done.
The skin thins for the lack of fluid within
and underneath it, giving that last little
bit of definition.
At the end of all that, you get exactly one
perfect day to get slicked over with baby
oil and tossed into tastefully-opaque bathwater
for five minutes of sexy footage.
For The Witcher, Cavill had to go through
this grueling process repeatedly for every
single one of the several scenes in which
he's featured shirtless, because his super-cut
physique can't be consistently maintained
for the weeks and weeks it takes to film a
TV series.
You're hungry and thirsty, and when you're
not working in front of a camera, you're still
working off-site in a gym with an entire team
of people monitoring you down to the finest,
dehumanizing detail.
Cavill said in the interview that by the end
of all those day-4 shoots, he had a peculiar
sensation.
"You get to the point on the last day where
you can smell water, like nearby."
Sounds like one of Geralt's special skills
…
"I smelled what you were doing!"
Bless Henry Cavill for his dedication and
patience, because this whole process sounds
like the absolute worst.
See the results for yourself on Netflix, where
Season 1 of the The Witcher is now streaming
in its entirety.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.